the other thing of course that comes
with being in shows is a publicity photo
shoots now I know you don't like them
Rob do you well only because the only
thing I can ever do in a photograph is
smile if I I'd loved to look you know
moody and did you look very beautiful
every time I've seen a photograph we you
look great James Bondish oh yes yeah
right where you going amazing well you
have a feeling you've got a great face
well all I can ever do is I do this is I
can show you if there's a camera that
that one there yeah I have to go like
this it makes the noise as well if I try
to be moody watch this
I just look confused every picture I'm
going look at the line of juicy still
there there you are look Nancy that's
good moody bar my very good burger that
you enjoy doing these Vicky the photo
she's not so much yes good in showbiz
you can do kind of you know jazz hands
you could be holding a chicken you can
do that but in drama but there are
presumably only so many poses available
yeah and Martin always bags with the
pockets first yeah you get on the shoe
and then you go to go in your pockets
and he's already done it
no we know sorted your arms here and
then as you say another line of juicy
you must have got into the proto shoes
and look at these bastards pockets
pockets you can't be happy yours he got
you stuck with the arm posing again then
coming to another room look at this
agent Dunbar he literally he sees a bar
he's on it marna the corner for Vicki
still holding her arm
thing else available to her then they go
they go okay I tell you what let's break
it up let's let's do one sitting at a
table folder you could be plugging in
the toy recorder anything so folding her
arms
then we get to replace I'll shut off
your swords a whole new fresh thing this
is a fresh start for Vickie fresh start
look the co-starring [__] in a weird
twist of fate ladies and gentlemen they
take another picture it's catching now
now it's exciting because oh she she
goes for a break now it's so low it's
just vickima pure by herself
please go she could pose anyways
that was a huge pass there's a huge car
of abroad trip right project and they're
doing a big group shot all on the beach
ideologue and just pan along you know so
there they all are there's one family
like half of it oh look that she's got
one hand in hands down hands down person
standing in a tent other family other
family we're all holding a hand nice
I've got pockets tonight oh we will
never see you tonight that won't ever
see you do that again absolutely bonkers
because all we're gonna do
[Music]
you